even asking questions about this
ideology uh is potentially harmful
i
at some point uh decided to ask a
question whether some actions inside of
the company
complied with
a company's policies about
discrimination
and i got reported for asking that
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kitchen
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people what a brilliant guest we have
for you today he is a former google
engineer who was fired by the company
for challenging some of the excesses of
the company's diversity agenda taraska
bernick welcome to trigonometry
uh hello constantine francis happy to be
here you are very kind uh brilliant it
was probably an overstatement but i will
try to
live to that
yes indeed well your story is very
interesting and i'm sure uh our audience
will find it very interesting given some
of the things that you've been through
before we get into taras please tell
everybody a little bit about what's your
background who are you how are you where
you are what has been the journey
through life that leads you to be
sitting here talking to us
most of it probably is not related to
the story uh i'm from ukraine i was born
there i moved to switzerland to work
with google at 2016 worked there for
four years as a software engineer
and
unfortunately it came to an end with me
trying to point out
certain things that we're getting far
from my perspective at the company and
becoming damaging
to the company's culture and probably
the future
and let's get into that right away
what was it that you were starting to
become concerned about because having
looked through some of the documents
involved in your case i can see that you
made repeated attempts in discussions
and forums in conversations internally
at google in response to various memos
and diversity initiatives and all of
that to challenge some of the things uh
that were happening and you were told
repeatedly that you were making other
people unsafe uh uncomfortable you were
being insensitive you were told that by
uh supporting jordan peterson's position
on pronouns uh you were making your
fellow employees quote unquote unsafe
etc so what was it that was happening
and why did you feel the need to speak
out against it
it was probably me being due to
the western culture because all my life
before that moment
i spent back in ukraine and the
approaches there are different
so when i
came to google i had to adjust to
working for a huge company working in
the west living in a different place it
was my basically first trip uh outside
of ex soviet union
and i also had to adjust to
the culture around
and not just to the local culture but
also to the american culture that is
prevalent at the company
and i tend to
pay attention to what her company tells
us during some
educational sessions like uh
when the company explains companies
policies and so on so when the company
tells me that discriminations are not
allowed on all these characteristics i
tend to trust that
and then when i see
some actions that do look like
discriminations at least in my book
by definition of treating people
uh
differently based on different traits
like race and so on i start asking
questions because
uh
it's either a violation of policies and
might be a problem along the term
or it is the company not being honest uh
and telling you one thing in policies
and then acting differently outside of
that
and that is
a problem because it starts hard to
trust the company in such case when you
don't know what to expect of the company
and also you don't know when the company
might start holding you responsible uh
because on paper uh
if you comply with what the company does
you start violating one thing or another
and then it's up to the company to
decide where to cash that uh and to hold
you responsible for that and since you
cannot properly trust the company you
cannot trust that
the company is going to be fair and
honest in uh holding you responsible so
it's useful to try to clarify things
and that's what i've been trying to do
well speaking of clarifying things
before francis jumps in because i know
he has a lot of questions for you just
to clarify uh for people who may be less
familiar with our sort of post-soviet
culture etc you're coming from a place
where the idea of
saying things as they are is encouraged
right in when in your uh
previous career before you moved to
switzerland you probably would have
thought well it's my job to listen to
what my employer tells me and to respond
to that honestly and directly
about what's happening and you move over
you find yourself at google which says
we must not discriminate against people
on the basis of their race their sex
their gender whatever and you take that
at face value
and you take that literally and you
start going well some of the stuff
you're saying about white people kind of
feels like discrimination to me and if i
go along with this i would now be
complicit in the very thing your company
says i must not do is that a fair
summation
yes
uh obviously uh you cannot just say
anything and without consequences back
in ukraine uh and companies might not be
happy with whatever your disagreement is
and you're supposed to comply with
policies but that's basically comes
first you're supposed to satisfy the
company's requirements like policies or
whatever and
uh that's why policies of google did
look like important to pay attention to
and so
let's just flesh out the working
environment what was it like to work at
google number one was it good was it
good or was there sort of this culture
of fear
uh it's a mixed uh feeling because there
are a lot of awesome things at google
there are a lot of wonderful
uh highly experienced people in their
areas
uh there are a lot of resources
obviously there are a lot of tools so
that uh probably not all of them are
available outside uh tools that help you
to
do your job
there are a lot of people that really
try to make your work pleasant and
to provide you with some additional
perks health whatever
at the same time
the company is obviously huge and
there are costs that come with that size
so not everything is
fast enough and there are some
bureaucratic complications there
and um i wouldn't say there is a
intentional culture of fear it's more
like
a lot of people try to stick to doing
their job and try not to try to avoid
contradicting the company or superiors
because uh despite the company
encouraging you to
do the right thing even at the cost to
yourself or challenge the status quo
which is stated in some companies
documents describing like positive
traits uh it's not always good because
if you start disagreeing with your
superiors it might go both ways
and uh there are awesome managers there
that really try to help you try to
figure out what the problem is and how
to
uh solve it but there are a lot of
people that uh
basically try to avoid unnecessary
responsibility
and try to uh spend time on what they
know best for example
most managers uh
are good at uh fields they are in like
an engineering manager might be
uh most probably a great engineer at
least a great engineer uh delivering
some products in time
that doesn't make such a person
good at interacting with people or
figuring out any interpersonal problems
or organizational problems so when such
a person becomes a manager
many seem to revert to this mode of
thinking oh i am a good engineer i'm
going to keep being a good engineer but
just now i have additional team to help
me deal with engineering stuff
and that becomes a problem because of
the company expects certain things to be
done in certain ways and uh expects
managers to handle some bureaucracy at
the company and when managers
self-eliminate from that all that burden
falls onto teams and it
makes things harder
and as for the ideological stuff it
applies to the extent that the company
does something for whatever
company reasons are not necessarily the
company is uh ideological but it
certainly supports some ideologies and
not others
and then it becomes terrorists could you
give an example where you said it
support certain ideologies but not
others
obviously my document
lists some examples of this
and we've
it's it wasn't the first case when i
started was asking questions but
in this case it was 2020
a lot of stuff was happening back in
the u.s
racial related stuff and we were getting
bombarded by
messages from the top management
regarding all these ideologies that we
have to educate ourselves about racism
and about june team and about slavery
and about everything and read
um books by robin d'angelo and others
and um
basically the situation is that you're
getting uh an email from your ceo with
such messages then from your senior vice
president your vice president vice
president's responsible for your office
vice presidents for uh european region
or whatever and all keep telling you
that you are supposed to educate
yourself and you are not supposed to be
a terrible person and it's not clear
uh
why uh they are trying to do that and
what they are trying to achieve other
than just to signal that they support
this stuff and uh as for not being able
to supporting one ideologies not others
even asking questions about this
ideology
is potentially harmful
i
at some point decided to ask a question
whether some actions inside of the
company
complied with
a company's policies about
discrimination
and i got reported for asking that uh
for two cases uh one
once i asked uh i formulated some
question and i used words alleged racism
because to me it didn't look like racism
what people were describing
uh and i got reported for using the word
alleged because apparently you are not
supposed to doubt that such things are
due to racism
and second case
i was pointing out of the that one of uh
allied ship resources available inside
of the company did look like
discriminatory uh
and why did you say that
um that's the resource that is mentioned
in my document and when there are
articles there like white people have no
culture or what do we do with white
people and so on uh they have they focus
on race and they uh blame people based
on race
uh and to me it already looks like
discrimination and most importantly
i don't see
what a good thing this could lead to
because i don't see good outcomes of
this
so i ask the question whether uh such a
resource was within companies policies
and i was reported for asking this
question uh also
because
the formerly
i was told that
[Music]
pointing out uh
um
like criticizing or questioning la ship
resources draws attention from uh the
anti-racism fight and so uh i was
intentionally drawing that attention
away from important things
uh
i didn't know that at the time i only
discovered these things later when i was
given a written warning with these
statements on it
i was given it right before getting
fired
so you're not supposed to doubt that
racism is there and you're not supposed
to even question whether some resources
are within companies policies and then
how do you act tyrus
that sounds incredibly sinister so when
you got that email from the vice
president the president saying you have
to read this book you have to read that
book did you have to read it or was it
advised to read it
it wasn't compulsory uh i know that in
some teams in the u.s people were
getting through some
learning sessions
and while they were not compulsory uh
skipping them
uh was
not something
people felt comfortable with because
the idea is if you
uh don't participate in this when you
are a terrible person because you don't
want to understand how to deal with
terrible stuff
uh luckily uh in europe it's different
uh we didn't have uh
even uh
optional trainings but we were getting a
lot of these emails from all the
management encouraging us to read all
that stuff
it's interesting that you yeah it seems
to me like a lot of people might look at
your situation and go well why would you
be discussing politics at work and you
know if if an employee
in in a company that sells coffee or
whatever came in and started spouting
off about blm you can see why their
manager would be like come on mate just
just make the coffees can't calm down
but in your case it seems like the
company brought the politics in
and you were then simply responding
based on your literal interpretation
possibly if i may say so as a fellow
post-soviet person because you kind of
took it at face value well these are the
requirements of my job i have to take
this information in process it and
respond accordingly and then having
politicized your role in everyone else's
role in the company the company then
essentially prompted people to be
talking about this political stuff but
there was only one particular vision
that you were supposed to have
uh
yes
kind of like that
um
there are multiple things here uh
so
the company tells us all the time
that
we are supposed to pay attention to bad
things happening around us we are uh we
are going through trainings that tell us
that we have to pay attention and report
uh violations and so on and then when it
looks like there are some
violations it becomes a problem
it's actually
even more complicated when there is all
this pressure because the company
doesn't always explain to you what
exactly the company wants
uh it's slightly uh step to the side but
i had a situation once when i got
reported for one discussion
and uh my manager had a meeting with me
and told me that
i
i was not to cross the line
and uh it wasn't clear what that line
was in that specific situation that he
was referring to so i asked for a
clarification uh could you please tell
me what that line is so i would avoid
crossing it the manager takes uh
a break um as far as incent meets some
uh hr's
then comes back and tells me
and i quote pretty closely that a
decision has been made not to clarify to
you where the line is because doing that
would enable you to go straight to that
line without crossing it and it's not
that uh something that the company wants
so it was intentional obscurity of
policies and uh in such cases how do you
act if you don't know what constitutes a
violation of a policy because then
whatever you do might be a violation and
you might be hold responsible
it's understandable that it's useful for
the company to
push all this responsibility onto
everyone around beat employees beat
customers because
you are customers of youtube
because you have to comply with
youtube's policies
don't we just [ __ ] know it taurus
we do
let me ask you something look obviously
your story uh and we'll get into some of
the consequences for you is deeply
painful i imagine and and difficult and
a lot of people will care about it but
also i think a question a lot of people
will have is how this affects them right
because if you have a company that
you know whether you believe it's
ideologically driven or not it certainly
seems like a particular ideological
slant exists within some of the policies
does do you believe that that is
reflected
in the product
in the google algorithms in the youtube
in all of that stuff is there any
element where that starts to bleed
through
i haven't seen
examples of that affecting our project
but i was just a part of some project
and not others
generally
i would avoid making statements like yes
it does affect products though we can
see that
google maps has for example released a
half a year ago a new feature where
businesses can mark themselves as owned
by black people or by women or something
like that and this is basically
coming from this idea of we having to
provide additional possibilities to
minorities and so on which results
basically in a
feature that
incentivizes people to discriminate each
other basically on
grounds of race
gender and so on
but in general
the thing is
for example with google search that i
was a part of like bigger ecosystem of
google search
when you make any changes to search you
are supposed to uh
figure out whether this is a good change
or not and it's hard to do that in
a big system same
goes for machine learning systems ai and
so on
and
this is often done by
having some references let's say search
queries
and you have a huge amount of them and
then you
check
whether
changes in outcomes of search
are
beneficial or not as a result of you
tweaking something
and there are people that
create such references and there are
people that
grade whatever deviations from known uh
search results
and uh then these people make decisions
whether some examples are good or not
whether some search results
are good matches for search queries and
so on
and when such people are subjects to all
this
environment where you have to
support or at least not to challenge
certain ideology
when they know that even questioning
whether something is good or not might
result in a problem for them they might
be
quite careful with
making their decisions for about such
references and
they might just avoid uh any
um basically tests for software that
might uh challenge of this narrative so
while people might not be
actively ideological they might just
take decisions not to
evaluate quality of some uh aspects of
products in order to avoid problems with
ideological stuff
but the reason i ask you is i'll give
you an example and maybe you can explain
to me what's going on obviously youtube
is also owned by google and i there's a
a right-wing uh american talk show host
a very famous tucker carson whose show
you've been on uh and i have noticed
that if you you know whether i'm doing
stuff for research or whatever when i
put tucker carlson in the first or
second video on the youtube search is
almost always someone on cnn
making fun of or debunking or mocking
tucker carson which seems quite unusual
like if you were to search for
trigonometry i'd be so you'd be very odd
to me that the first search results
wouldn't be from trigonometry there
would be somebody making fun of
trigonometry not that anyone would do
that of course
well you do uh you make a good fun of it
yourself when you get to that yeah uh as
for search results on youtube and so on
it's actually different a difficult
question it's pretty easy to see it as a
result of ideologies and some
malice but it's not necessarily that
because all these algorithms they have
to deal with uh so huge uh amounts of
information that you uh
cannot potentially test everything
and uh you cannot always uh
it's basically impossible to have some
decision making system that would be 100
correct uh
so uh you always try
trying to
make improvements uh
and your improvements most probably
result in some
um
detrimental effects to some other parts
like let's say that you
would try to make sure that tucker
carlson gets proper search results and
then you make some changes to the
algorithm and then whatever cnn deutsche
welle uh bbc would start getting
slightly worse search results and then
it's up to you to decide whether overall
increase in quality is good enough to
justify that slight drop in some areas
or not and you cannot uh get to 100
correctness so uh
it might be possible to look at specific
results and try to figure out what's
happening there but uh uh i wouldn't say
that it is uh the company's malice or
whatever that is responsible for such
results
i find that very upsetting tariffs i
thought that youtube were against us has
made me angry but look teres
why i still can't get my head around
this why is it that these big
juggernaut multinational corporations
making billions why do they get involved
in this stuff if it's going to cause
anger if it's going to cause
divisiveness within their own ranks and
ultimately lower productivity
i hope that you would be able to tell me
you've had so many wonderful uh guests
on your show and uh much more suited to
[Music]
explore uh
reasons behind such changes i really
don't know why the company supports it i
haven't seen
uh
some evidence of the management being
ideological
but i don't know what they say in
private uh
and when they
talk in public it's not clear whether
they support this because they
really think this is a good ideology uh
because they are trying to get some
benefits for the company by supporting
this ideology or simply because they are
afraid to touch uh some topics uh
for example there was um
a situation in uh
the beginning of
summer 2019
there was one company's employee a
manager from youtube uh in
los angeles who did notice uh
some random black person trying to
bypass some security measures on an
apartment building of that uh google's
employee
and uh so that employee uh did confront
that black person
the situation uh escalated and ended up
with
the employee calling the police and uh
being filmed on camera and that ended up
on
public news as a white youtube executive
calling the police on a black man or
something like that
and there was a lot of unhappiness
inside of the company uh
people were claiming they were unsafe
working with this employee
there was a meeting between
so-called blacks at youtube an affinity
group
in youtube for as far as understand
black employees and their allies
they had according to the internal
messaging boards a meeting with uh the
ceo of youtube susan fujitsuki
and uh after that
and they as far as incent were trying to
express their unhappiness with the
situation
and susan uh has decided to address this
uh
during a company-wide meeting so called
tgf we still had them back then uh later
the company cancelled uh most of them
so susan was aware of the situation
she was addressing it
on her own initiative she was able to
prepare
she obviously thought that
the topic was important enough because
she walked in the middle of regular
presentations uh usually doesn't happen
uh she didn't she decided not to wait
for uh
the standard uh questions and answers
session at the end and decided to
address the situation in the middle of
that meeting
and she said that basically the company
uh i'm trying to be close uh that the
company valued uh
black employees a lot and so that the
safety of the black employees was
paramount to the company and so on
nobody was
challenging that position
so it wasn't clear why she was stating
that and she said absolutely nothing
about
this
whether it was fine to call the police
in that situation for the employee or
not
uh so with people claiming being unsafe
and asking several questions on that q a
session
about uh consequences to that employee
whether the company would take some
action against that employee
uh susan never addressed that uh and
then uh the ceo of google sunder pichai
also uh said few words but he basically
repeated uh the same sentiment and also
avoided addressing the question of
a mob of black employees and their
allies basically harassing that white
employee
for
calling the police on a suspected
trespasser
uh
that employee
was uh wasn't fired as far as i
understand
but uh
the company that claims that
discrimination is bad and that
the company that even mentioned on my uh
on the statement about me for uh tucker
carlson show
that i was apparently a bad person for
singling out some person i have no idea
what that is about
uh the company was obviously fine with
all this mob
uh singling out that employee and going
after that employee
uh i don't know why the company reacted
that way uh my best guess is that uh
despite being uh
aware of the situation and having time
to prepare the management had no idea
how to address it
uh because uh over time it's not like
the management has been
displaying great problem-solving skills
to the rest of the company so that could
have been just a result of further
management being afraid of doing
anything
and and teres so you see this happening
in the company you see the way that the
political climate is going
do not worry about
yourself
and doing the actions that you'd that
you have then done
because you must have been worried you
must have known where this was going to
end up
i wasn't worrying that much for myself
though it was obviously affecting me
when i was being called
being referred to as a terrible person
because of being white basically
but
what was worrying me even more is that
the company didn't look capable of
addressing such situations and
being clear with its employees or with
customers
and that says something about companies
ability to address other challenges and
when so much in your life uh depends on
how good your employer is good as in the
sense of business sense whether you have
future there and so on and then you see
this uh
such actions
uh that
make you think that the company is not
capable of addressing actual uh problems
that was uh
troublesome
but in general uh about this situation
yes i don't see how this can
proceed without ending with uh
one out of two
outcomes either
uh people accept all this uh state of
things and just submit to it
and uh i do not i won't be able to do
that myself and i wouldn't wish that on
to my friends
or there is going to be real conflict
and uh potential misery down the road
and whatever the outcome of that
conflict i'm
not looking forward to that
so yes i uh
i thought it was necessary to try to fix
the problem the idea basically is that
you uh love it fix it or leave it uh i
saw it as a problem i uh
saw it as affecting let's say my
reputation because when i joined google
uh my reputation started contributing to
google's although it was very small
contribution
but google's reputation started
affecting me and if the company you work
for
starts doing bad things
and you
say nothing
like i would feel myself
responsible or at least
it would be possible for people to blame
me for such things so i had to do
something i wasn't able to love the
situation i wasn't ready to leave
uh and i tried to fix it that's why i've
been asking questions internally that's
why i wrote this document and i actually
wrote this document after a
conversation in our team because uh it
wasn't just me being unhappy but other
people as well though most of people
are not uh
as uh
able to
talk about this stuff because they worry
about their families and so on i was in
slightly better position unfortunately
don't have a family but that does make
things a bit easier for me
so
in the end of that conversation my
manager asked me
uh about my specific concerns and told
me that these concerns would be
[Music]
sent somewhere upstairs or whatever and
i decided to write a document because uh
it's hard to just keep telling uh stuff
to people in such a big company because
everyone has their own problems to work
on different time zones and whatever so
when you try to address something it's
much better to write a document and then
share the document so people can read it
at their spare time i wrote the document
i shared it with
the manager so he would be able to use
it and i also shared it with our team
because of that conversation and with
some other people i've been having
i had
i had similar conversations with
and that's when problems started because
apparently the company wasn't happy with
that
and for people who haven't read the
document uh what was the gist what was
the overall message that you you said
uh
i saw these ideologies getting too far
and damaging uh becoming contradictory
with a company's own policies and
damaging long-term to the culture and to
the reputation of the company
and uh i also saw it as a problem that
it was hard for people to
point that out because i knew plenty of
people that were not happy with this but
that were afraid of speaking up
and that
was also something that i mentioned in
my document
uh actually after i started getting
pressured by
my manager i contacted one of higher
managers director level
with something like 50 80 people
reporting to him and i asked for uh
advice there because
i wasn't getting any good advice from my
manager
uh okay maybe my document is awful but
let me know how i can express these
thoughts in an appropriate manner and i
was i never got that response and i
asked that question again during the
meeting with hr when i was getting fired
and i also didn't get any explanation
how i can express these things in a way
that would be considered
uh possible the company tells you all
the time that
you are free to discuss whatever you
want
and then there is a
small print caveat that communications
have to be
respectful and so on
and then it's up to the company to
decide what is considered to be
disrespectful and
the company doesn't actually tell you
what uh
is your
mistake and how to fix it uh again
probably because uh whatever the company
says it is afraid that it might be used
against its somewhere later so it's
uh more beneficial for the company to
avoid providing you with enough
information
so i contacted that director level
manager and i asked him for help
and the answer was do what your manager
tells you and also you're wrong that you
think uh
that it's not safe to talk about these
matters inside of the company
because that's uh most probably because
uh you've never engaged with all these
wonderful la ship resources our company
provides
and then i was encouraged to join some
lsu group and to learn about racism and
so on and i don't know what was more
disturbing there whether
um
of
an engineer and a
high manager with a lot of people
depending on him not understanding this
uh environment that the company creates
and problems that come with it or uh
understanding it and
consciously uh
stepping away
and to avoid
making things complicated for himself
and letting uh subordinates basically to
deal with all this uh on their own
taurus was there any point where you
were working for google you went this
reminds me of the soviet union
oh uh
okay uh if i would say that i wouldn't
be
uh
totally correct because uh i was lucky
uh
to
be about 13 when the soviet union
collapsed uh luckily it collapsed before
i did
uh so uh i
i was only able to judge about the
soviet union
uh based on conversations with parents
friends of the family reading books
movies and so on so it's not like
my personal experience with the soviet
union with a lot of stuff
but
a lot of nonsense that happens not just
with google but it looks like in
corporate world in politics uh it's just
ridiculous it's uh
um all these statements about uh
supporting some ideologies and having to
uh
to be the beacon of flights or whatever
uh
all that stuff was happening in the
soviet union with uh actual results not
being that great and so on as far as i
understand
so yeah uh
there are
better people to make such a comparison
but uh i guess uh
uh some people after getting fed all
that nonsense in
the soviet union and post-soviet union
times in
countries controlled by the soviet union
like poland and others uh maybe they're
a little better
maybe not better equipped but uh maybe
they have little
less patience
to all this nonsense than others that
are not familiar with this yeah well
that that makes sense to me
and
obviously
you you then get fired for for refusing
to not share that document so your
manager said to you you there is no
problem discussing this issue or rather
this director manages no problem talking
about this stuff at google go ahead i
mean go and read all the right
literature of course but but there's no
problem you can say what you want and so
you said what you want
and then they tried to get you to unsay
it
and when you refused they fired you is
that correct
uh yes i don't know why the company
didn't order me to delete the document
maybe again it was trying to
save
to maintain some perception that things
are allowed at the company so you don't
have to delete the document i was told
that you just have to make the comp the
document not accessible by other people
which results in the same
and uh which sounds as a nonsense and
i've been asking my manager repeatedly
uh like what is wrong with my document
and if i am so dumb that i am unable to
express my thoughts in a good way could
you please tell me how i can do that
my manager wasn't capable to do that i
wouldn't
get into details of that because again
that's just
decisions and
qualities of one person that might not
be indicative of the company in general
uh but uh
it wasn't the first
time when i got in this situation we
allow you to talk about things but you
have to talk about them in a way we see
appropriate and we won't tell you what
the appropriate is
it wasn't the first time when i was
asking hr's
um about ways to talk about things
without getting uh reported you already
mentioned that
the case about jordan peterson's
pronouns and it was actually ridiculous
because
uh it was a conversation where someone
asked the question something like if
only i knew why people act the way they
do
and that could have been a sarcastic
remark uh but i decided to try to
respond to it
and uh
it's not like i knew a lot of about
psychology uh maybe nowadays i would
have recommended uh lectures by robert
sapolsky from stanford uh but back then
i was going through university lectures
by jordan peterson
the maps of meaning
and despite me uh
not
following all conclusions by dr peterson
i was fascinated by
how he was getting to some interesting
ideas based on whatever
sources he was using
so i and it was useful for me to a
certain extent so i decided to recommend
these lectures
by that time i already i have already i
had already
heard about such things as
microaggressions and trigger warnings
so i decided to do my best to
provide a trigger warning so i mentioned
that jordan peterson uh was considered
by some people controversial because of
his stance on the compelled speech
which resulted in uh all this conversa
around transgender pronouns
uh but uh
from my point of view it was due to
representation of his stance and that
was basically my comment
uh almost immediately someone commented
that how dare you to mention jordan
peterson because i have a
sibling who is trans and this is so
painful and now you are mentioning this
terrible person
and then i got reported for
um
for uh
supporting jordan peterson's stance on
transgender pronouns which uh
wasn't i believe the point of my comment
so you can get in such a strange
situations as well so basically you
mentioned someone who some people don't
like and that that that becomes you
making people unsafe now
uh
yes and uh
around that time i also heard about some
attempts to invite people like
dr peterson to give a talk
at some google office google has
has been
inviting different people and there are
there is a channel called talks at
google or something like that on youtube
where you can uh watch all this and
there are people like john cleese for
example uh
and uh some of these stocks are fun to
watch
uh but uh people were not getting
approvals for uh inviting jordan
peterson and at the same time robin
d'angelo the author of the white
fragility book was given a talk at one
of the offices it was actually my first
topic that i
got engaged in because i had no idea how
the concept of white fragility might not
be a violation of company's policies
about uh racial discrimination
so
teres
look you're looking at the journey that
you've had you look at everything that's
happened do you regret speaking out
uh i regret losing my
google salary and
putting my swiss
visa in danger because it's hard to stay
here if i don't have a good job and not
that easy always to find
a suitable job
i don't regret speaking up i probably
would have regretted if i stayed silent
basically it was
quite uncomfortable for me and it was uh
not
i would say it was uh detrimental for my
uh
state uh
in addition to all the uh pressure that
uh there is uh their uh
engineering-wise regarding your work
there was this uh
pressure with ideologies i wasn't able
to support and pressure with all this
nonsense
and
with the company not being able to
formulate things and the company
basically acting
hypocritically and
avoid putting all the blame onto you uh
avoiding providing you information in
order to be able to navigate all these
complexities it was making things harder
actually
i was already thinking about leaving
google at some point even before that uh
but i i was still not ready to do that
but so this pressure actually drives
some people away from the company i know
people that do leave company because of
all this nonsense about uh because of
all this pressure
and what has been the impact on your
life you mentioned losing your salary in
your job you are still looking for a job
now uh google haven't exactly i mean you
can see why after
all of the complaints uh that they had
about you they wouldn't give you a a
good reference but uh you you still
haven't found another job
and it's been a year right
uh it's not like i've been looking for a
new job all the time i really needed
some break
after google and after some time i
really felt way better than i
uh felt uh while looking working for the
company
yes it's a bit hard
for various reasons for me to find
something here
and
regarding the reference sure i totally
agree that uh
first of all i agree that a company
should be able to
get rid of an employee that for some
reason is not good for the company
otherwise it just wouldn't make any
sense from
um
business reasons whatever
what i uh don't agree is the way
it went because
basically the company was putting on to
me
the blame for
situations
created by the company
for whatever
contradictions been there and then
instead of just telling me look i know
that we that you don't support this
ideologies we do uh
it's not going to work for us let's
figure out how to part our ways i would
have understood that i would have
understood if the company
just told us that yeah we're going to
discriminate people based on race
because we think it's better for us
uh at least uh there wouldn't be uh
wouldn't have been this contradiction
for me uh like different messages from
the company
i was expecting a slightly different
outcome but the company actually
acted uh quite unfriendly both through
all this process and afterwards you
mentioned
the reference and again i agree that how
can someone
who
gets fired
get a good reference letter
but there are actually some
regulations regarding that here in
switzerland basically uh reference
letters are supposed to be written in
such a way to help uh the former
employee to find a new job you are not
supposed to blackmouth
that employee and uh you're supposed to
only mention negative stuff if that
was directly related to your job like uh
if i was a driver and i was drinking
alcohol during my work hours that would
have been on a reference letter
that of course makes reference letters a
bit
less useful because uh you cannot
properly explain why
have you decided to fire someone but uh
some people even uh
getting fired for under performance and
getting fired in
after
the company having bad perception are
still getting
uh great reference letters as far as i
know in my case the company has decided
to
provide me with a bad one that was also
contradicting my previous performance
reviews and was basically questioning
both my personal skills uh
uh the reference letter tells something
like uh that i was so disrespectful with
my fellow employees
a fellow colleagues that the company had
to intervene
and
when i was trying to negotiate with the
company about that the company told me
so what that you can bring and again i'm
quoting pretty closely so what that you
can bring 10 colleagues that would
testify that you were a wonderful
colleague we're going to bring uh
testaments from five people that were
offended by whatever you posted on
internal message boards and then it's
going to be up to some judge to decide
who is uh more right
now overall it
has resulted in me losing a lot of time
trying to
negotiate for a better reference letter
and a lot of money spent on lawyers
the company wasn't
even trying to
talk to me so it was basically stalling
for a lot of time not replying which is
not that great and uh
talking about you as customers of uh
clients of youtube uh that's basically
one of the
standards uh standard approaches of
designing interfaces be it uh like
graphical interface of a program or a
process through which people have to go
in order to contact the company and to
get some support or whatever
uh i've never been posting anything on
youtube you know better but are you
getting good enough explanations from
youtube when some of your videos gets
unlisted or demonetized
whether some of your
some of the comments on your videos are
getting deleted are you getting enough
information to prevent such things from
happening in the future and do you
understand why exactly is that happen
because if it doesn't it's the same
problem the company is taking all this
responsibility onto you uh the company
is not being friendly and uh not trying
to
been fair and the company has this uh
so-called culture of three respects
respect each other respect
the customer and there's respect the
opportunity
it was
getting installed somewhere
two years ago maybe
and i'm not prepared to talk about
opportunities but at least with regard
to respecting each other and customers i
would say that the company does a
terrible job because by not providing
you with proper information so you would
be able to uh interact with the company
uh it makes your lives easier and
it basically puts responsibility on to
you in order to avoid responsibilities
itself and this is not a good uh
partnership and the same happens with
internal communications when you don't
understand what's happening and so
all these situations at the company so
respecting each other also
doesn't work that greatly inside of the
company that makes sense but we wish you
all the best with finding new employment
and now that you feel better about
everything thank you for coming to speak
to us uh we've got a few questions for
our local supporters we've also got a
final question uh is is there any way
people can get in touch with you if they
want to uh or find you online or
anything like that
uh they can probably find me on linkedin
or on my protomail account
taurus.comernick
thanks very much well we've got one more
question in the main interview for you
which is what's the one thing we're not
talking about but we really should be
uh
if only i knew what you've been talking
about because i didn't have as much time
to watch all your wonderful podcasts
but i'm curious whether
how we can
improve
overall education system
i know that you've discussed it briefly
with dr
heather heinz and bert weinstein during
your recent podcast uh live stream
but uh there you were addressing it from
the point of view of
changing maybe creating new institutions
instead of the existing universities and
so on
i wonder
about uh accessibility of good
mentorship to people because uh
sometimes you
it's nice if you know what questions to
ask
then you can go to sites like quora or
whatever and try to find some answers or
google for something sometimes you don't
even know what questions to ask and good
mentorship is important unfortunately
not everyone can get one
usually it's parents and your teachers
that are supposed to help you but not
everyone can help you for example my
parents were
never able to advise me on creating my
own business or invest in things those
were not things in the soviet union and
so uh in the other countries as well
so
i think there is a lot of value in good
mentorship i don't know how to make it
accessible
and
maybe we can create something that is
not perfect but uh the next best thing
we have uh all these uh wonderful online
courses available from leading uh
universities and uh they were of great
help for me for example because without
them i wouldn't have been able to get to
even to google or any other close
uh so maybe there is some way to
have
some educational institutions that are
not about having
uh awesome scientists uh on stuff
and instead of leveraging these
educational uh courses from online
platforms and instead focusing on
providing good mentorship or whatever
and for instance would be able to tell
more about this with
your background
in education i don't have that
experience but would be nice to discuss
that
no it's it's something that would be
very very interesting to discuss terrace
thank you so much for coming on thanks
for being with us absolutely yeah well
it's been a pleasure for us to thank you
and thank you for watching guys at home
and if you've enjoyed the show please
remember that wednesdays and sundays 7
p.m uh british time 2 p.m eastern
standard time or when our interviews go
out tuesdays thursdays fridays and
saturdays 7 p.m 2 p.m our raw shows and
if you want to enjoy trigonometry on the
move because you're back at work it's
also available as a podcast take care
and see you soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button so that you never miss
another fantastic episode and if you
believe that the work we do here at
trigonometry is important support us by
joining our locals community using the
link below